what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are jumping into Red Hood in
the outlaws yeah that's right hood in
the outlaws okay let me tell you
something man this is like one of the
best stories that I've ever read in
comic books ever
when Scott lowdown decides to bring out
the big guns that's exactly what he does
and it is amazing to see like the whole
run of Red Hood has been stellar but I
think this story is probably the best
story so far so initially what this does
is this picks up what really with like
Red Hood in the in the apartment of a
guy now this initially kind of refreshes
people on Red Hood because a lot of
people who are familiar with the
character of Red Hood always sort of
made the old kind of saw him is
something akin to like The Punisher
right like a guy who goes in and just
kills villains everywhere he finds them
but in Red Hood and The Outlaws he's
more tame and he doesn't really do that
because again the promise was made to
Batman that he would try Batman's way of
doing things which was basically
stopping crime without actually killing
people and it's a really really cool
moment here because what this does is it
will change everything in a lot of
different ways and initially this picks
up with essentially just like a mobster
who's shown up into town for the purpose
of doing business with Oswald Cobblepot
now a lot of people look at this and
they say okay for the character of the
penguin he's always somewhat of a
background character he's a main villain
of Batman but you don't see him all that
often but he does have a lot of business
dealings he's an arms dealer he deals in
drugs and you know money laundering and
all kinds of different things and so
where Red Hood is able to instill enough
fear in this guy to basically send him
packing
at the end of the day he still doesn't
and it's one of these things we look
kind of reluctant because one thing to
bear in mind is that when it comes to
criminals in Gotham City by and large is
very easy to recognize them as just kind
of being a Gotham City element right
like the Joker operates outside at you
know inside of Gotham City and two faces
in Gotham but a lot of these guys
because they're part of the criminal
underworld have some pretty long fingers
being able to reach out into other parts
of the world they don't normally visit
and so if you were to screw over the
penguin just because you leave the US
doesn't mean you're not gonna die and so
it's really a dangerous precedent to get
in bed with a villain on that scale and
so it's kind of intriguing here because
what this does is it switches over to
Artemus and bizarro
now remember Bizarros intelligence is
basically been degrading over time with
regards to the events that have been
going on Lex Luthor had basically
injected him with kind of a a serum that
sort of completed him that it was only
ever really a temporary thing and the
time when calm would when basically it
would begin to drop off and Artemus has
been very very hesitant about Bizarros
character which is to say she's been
very unsure about whether or not he's
actually a good guy and so her talking
to him is more or less you've been
manipulate
you've been using us to your own ends
we're not as smart as you are so we
can't easily pick up on what it is
you're doing but just be aware I'm
keeping an eye on I want to know what
you're doing
but if you're not gonna tell me that
I'll basically keep an eye out and see
what's going on now from here we switch
over to one of the coolest things Scott
Liddell almost does a kind of mini mad
report and what I mean by that is in
Marvel Comics you have a an island a
really a country called mad report and
it's like a criminal Haven is what it is
no one really goes there superheroes
don't go there because what goes on in
magic or is is like the Wild West you go
in there you screw somebody over it's
like it's like Mad Max Beyond
Thunderdome break a wheel and you'll
break a deal face the wheel it's one of
those crazy things and so with this we
kind of pick up in this hotel where it's
kind of like a hotel for henchmen
whereas like all these guys who have
been henchmen for various villains over
the years are all sort of meeting with
each other and they talk about jobs
they're doing and they sort of exchange
information like hey the penguin has a
really really good gig coming out if
you're looking to get work over there
and it's kind of cool you almost always
assume something like that existed but
you never really gave it a whole lot of
thought it was never like I wonder if
the henchmen from different villains
meet up and if like henchmen you know
sort like to hitch-pin will work for
two-face and then one of them will find
a more stable gig working for the Joker
it's a really cool thing but with Zorro
shows up here and the reason why is
because initially he had basically said
hey look I've got this project I'm gonna
go work on I might go do my own thing
but Jason Todd even has his own
reservations and following bizarro to
this hotel the end of finding out
bizarro gases the whole place where the
intention of killing all these henchmen
but that's one of the things that it's
really more of a stopgap measure say
bizarro had gone through with this which
of course he does and he basically ends
up stopping kind of taking pity on them
and saying look you guys are in
desperate times and that's that's kind
of why you do this but say bizarro had
actually gone through with it and killed
them all it would just be more because
in Gotham City there's no lack of supply
for people who are struggling
financially and so there's always people
looking for like an easy gig looking for
easy money or people who are on hard
times and trying to do it they can give
him what skillset they have and so with
with you know widowhood kind of charming
in and saying hey look did you see me
because I was invisible did you stop
because of me
Bizarros responses no I did it because
I'm ashamed of killing all these people
but aren't miss appearing around and in
Bizarros room she ends up stumbling
across a hidden location and finds like
these giant vats of green kryptonite and
then in turn bizarro appears and is just
kinda like I wish you hadn't done that
and that's what we end up finding out
that what Bizarros been doing is
self-medicating he's basically an addict
and it's kind of a crazy thing he's just
using synthesized kryptonite in order to
keep his intelligence up his room for
bizarro is essentially the opposite of
Superman and so we're green kryptonite
would kill Superman green kryptonite
seems to give bizarro life more or less
to kind of enhance his abilities and
push them even further but he's
basically an addict because of the fact
that his intelligence has been dropping
off what he's been doing is ingesting
green kryptonite in order to keep his
intelligence up and it's a crazy thing
it's an addicts confession it's
basically what it is and so from there
you end up switching over to Jason Todd
now this is kind of cool because Jason
Todd is met by like this super hot chick
right he like takes into a private room
after he's basically been gaming the
money for like like gaming you know for
like all this money and everything and
when he gets in there he ends up finding
out he was brought there by the penguin
and the reason why is because what Jason
Todd had done as he had stolen money
from the penguin and then laundered it
through the kid through the Penguins
casino that was his intention was to bet
it in the casino and basically hit legit
cash instead and is actually not the
worst decision ever inevitably he was
caught he was busted you know and the
Penguins kinda like okay so like now we
got it you know we gotta do business as
usual but I want to switch to a bizarro
forcing this is a really really cool
moment there's this conversation that
bizarro has with Artemus after she busts
him after she catches him the question
is asked why would you do this like why
would you turn to like drug use you know
essentially self-medicating with with
kryptonite and his answer is because I
don't want to go back to being who I was
before I don't want to go back to being
the guy that can't form complete
sentences to the guy that can't really
string two thoughts together I don't
want to be that guy anymore
and when the questions asked what's so
wrong with that is it's basically like
but I've tasted what it can be like like
I've seen the world as it can be for me
I've been on this side of the line and
I'm terrified of going back because
imagine that one day you're essentially
a buffoon you're a complete and total
goof and then the next day the universe
is at your fingertips there's nothing
you can't do you are bound by nothing
would you really just give that up and
it's such a great question to ask
it's such an interesting scenario now of
course he eventually goes in for the
kiss and gets rejected like it's kind of
sad to see but it's kind of interesting
at the same time but what this does is a
kind of leads it's almost a shifting of
stories because where you have bizarre
or sort of fixing himself and accepting
that this is the this is what's gonna
happen that that either he can
self-medicate and who knows what the end
result of this will be or he can just
allow things to progress and for him to
regress back to his normal bizarro form
he ends up making the choice to regress
he destroys these these vats of green
kryptonite what you have is Jason Todd
who's kind of going down this really
really dark path Jason Todd is basically
met by the granddaughter
Fagin when he goes out and you know
roasted like a cafe to a coffee shop
more or less now Fagin is a character
who's old school in DC Comics and we
talked about her previously in in in red
hood rebirth so if you guys would know
more about her feel free to go check out
the the earlier Red Hood stories you'll
find links down in the description but
when it came to her character she
basically used kids for you know to kind
of fund her lavish lifestyle use them
for crime for criminal acts more or less
and she took advantage of them and so
because that Jason Todd didn't have the
best upbringing when he was in that
orphanage but this this granddaughter of
fake gun shows up and she essentially
says look there are these these letters
you know if they'd uh never went missing
or died I was instructed to bring these
letters to you because you're the only
one she ever really trusted that these
letters are supposed to be written for
you I don't know what they are I just
know that they're inside this envelope
and I have no clue what's going to
happen here and so it's kind of kind of
curious because in the question becomes
what's in there and so what we end up
doing is switching over to Artemis
talking to Lex Luthor now this is one of
the cool things because initially when
Lex Luthor had injected bizarro with
green kryptonite the assumption was that
he was doing it out of altruism right
because he was a good guy at the time
like he was he was good guy Lex Luthor
he was trying to do the right thing and
it made sense what we end up finding out
is according to Lex Luthor that was
never the case now take this for what
it's worth because maybe Lex Luthor is
lying maybe he doesn't want to show his
sensitive side we don't really know here
but what he basically says is you guys
were only ever an experiment that's all
you guys ever work I wanted to know how
bizarro would function if he was
perfected essentially and then sent out
into the world and you guys were the
ones who would keep him under control
you were the control agents that's all
you ever work he's gonna go back to his
old self that's what he needs that's
what needs to happen that's the way
things need to be and it's kind of crazy
because Lex Luthor sort of makes this
comment where he says like father like
son and it's not an offhanded remark
it's a remark of everybody goes back to
the way they used to be that bizarro is
returning back to his for him when he
was basically dumb and Lex Luthor's back
to being a bad guy it's kind of an
ironic statement it's intriguing when
you look at it for what it is and so
what I want to do is I want to switch
over to the real meat and potatoes of
this story like that really the best
part of this story which is when Jason
Todd begins reading the letters now
we're gonna kind of do this a little bit
out of order in terms of how the how it
actually starts versus where the letters
are but this basically picks up in the
old house of Fagin and when he starts
going through these letters they
basically tells him look this first
letter that I'm sending you this is from
me and I kept this hidden from you you
have letters from your father that I
never I never showed you and so when you
read these letters you have to keep an
open mind and this is probably some of
the most beautiful
storytelling then I've ever seen this is
classic Scott low Deltora a storytelling
because what ends up happening is the
father of Jason Todd sits down and says
I was basically a scumbag like I'm in
prison right now and I was a scumbag
back in the day I never really had
anything going for me I sold rugs
whoever would buy this but then one day
I met your mom who is this beautiful
woman and sure I sold to her but I
wanted to make a life with her and as
that time began to progress as that
began to happen I began to realize she
was an incredible person and so
eventually what happens is the mother of
Jason takes his father takes two takes
Willis to go meet her parents
and they freak out they're like you're
dating a drug dealer how could you be so
insane to believe that dating a drug
dealer could ever really work out but
love knows no bounds all love cares
about is emotion how do you feel about a
person and so because of the fact that
the two of them were in love they ended
up moving out to some really crappy part
of town and they were basically living
in like this really really ratty
apartment and then one day she gets
pregnant they had all these experiences
where they were falling in love and they
were creating a family and it's really
one of these things were the father of
Jason look to the horizon is that we can
make a life here I mean sure won't be
the most extravagant life but we'll be
together and that's the only thing that
will ever really matter that when he
looks at his son he says I don't want
you to become like me you are going to
be the Prince of Gotham City you're
going to rule it all one day you're
gonna you're gonna be the guy that you
know that I can look up to one day that
I can look at you and say as a father
I'm proud and so eventually what happens
is Jason taught himself gets sick and
Scott Liddell leaves us a little
ambiguous you know his father kind of
hints what maybe it's bad genes or
something like that you know he doesn't
really seem to indicate the Jason Todd
had overdosed on anything that he had
somehow access to drugs of his father
but whatever the reason is he ended up
getting sick and the result was that he
was going to need all kinds of treatment
which were exceedingly expensive and so
in order to basically do this his father
left you know when when he had gone
clean he left the the clean life and
gone to become a henchman and where he
bounced from villain to villain the way
he describes this is almost like he's
moving up in the ranks I've worked in
the big-time and eventually he ends up
getting a gig working for Oswald
Cobblepot ends up working for the
penguin and in this instance what the
penguin does is he uses his father as a
fall guy and so essentially when when
everything comes crashing down when the
actions of the penguin are revealed his
father's the one that ends up taking the
rap and he gets 20 years to life and
it's just kind of a crushing thing
because as Jason starts going through
and reading these letters he's making
this connection to this father that he
never really knew anything about and his
father wasn't a guy who just abandoned
him he was a father who was doing the
best he could and wanted his
to become better than he was and so at
the tail end of this Jason Todd finds
some pictures that he and his father
took when he was really really young and
Jason Todd seemingly loses it and what
he ends up doing is going to a cemetery
and starts digging up the grave of his
dad only to find the coffins empty and
initially the Penguins gonna destroy it
he's gonna kill him and the penguin just
says no and he basically just leaves he
essentially walks away and so what this
does is this leads to Jason Todd
confronted the penguin because this
great big huge ceremony that's put on
you know in response to everything
that's going on with you night of the
monster man and so on and so forth but
it's basically saying like look at
Oswald Cobblepot this guy who's given so
much to the city and a lot of people
know what he's about they know that he's
basically crooked that he's a monster
but he's putting money in all the right
pockets and because he's doing that
those in power are essentially turning a
blind eye but Jason Todd is not having
any of it this is the return of classic
Jason Todd that's the one people love
the most people like to see and be a
good guy but if you walk up to most Red
Hood fans and you say if you had to
choose between the one you have in
rebirth or the version from under the
Red Hood which one would you pick they
would say oh under the Red Hood an
instant no questions asked and I'm
curious leave a comment let me know
which one would you guys take you know
the younger the Red Hood version the
vigilante like the will kill villains
version or like the one that we have
from DC rebirth because I know the one
for rebirth and even new to duty when he
was teamed up with Arsenal a lot of he
developed a big fan base there and a lot
of people really did like that version
of his character but when he busts in
here the penguin kind of looks at him
and is like oh wow Red hoods here okay
so the guy who like who's basically mini
Batman do your thing we'll do our little
dance we'll do our little song though
take me to jail I'll be out everything
will be okay
and Jason Todd's response is no I'm not
coming here to make a min I'm not coming
here to take you to jail I'm coming here
to do what should have been done the
entire time I'm coming here to put a
bullet in your head and it's just like
damn because the penguin didn't expect
that Jason's heart takes off his mask
reveals his identity and by proxy
reveals the identity of Batman you know
basically saying like I am a kid who was
taken in by Bruce Wayne we and just
connecting the dots all the similarities
they have together penguin immediately
picks up on the fact that Batman is
Bruce Wayne but for Jason Todd he
doesn't care because penguins not gonna
live long enough to be able to tell
anybody what's going on and so it's kind
of crazy because everyone's in shock by
this the cop
the cops are totally baffled by the fact
they're red hoods about to kill the
penguin and it is almost kind of nuts
because the Penguins final final
responses well good on you kid
good on
you're falling into the criminal element
just like everybody else it's a
cutthroat world there's the strong and
those who were too weak to make it and
so what is up happening is in this
moment right before he pulls the trigger
Jason Todd muses to himself and he says
on the day I was born my father swore
did I would be the Prince of Gotham and
then he pulls the trigger shoots the
penguin in the face and says now I am
and it's just like damn like it's Scott
Liddell give it up for Scott Liddell
ladies and gentlemen the other half of
this is that with everything that's
going on with bizarre with his
intelligence progressing the ships more
or less going into self-destruct and so
Jason Todd's immediate response once he
ends up figuring out what's going on
it's to go over there and check it out
but while that's happening while Artemis
is dealing with the ship crashing into
Gotham while Jason Todd's racing back
over to to where the ships out of where
it's gonna land trying to find a way to
get in there him shooting Oswald
Cobblepot in the face is all being
watched by Bruce Wayne all being watched
by Batman and when Alfred chimes in he
says the whole bat family is on the
phone like Dick Grayson Barbara Gordon
Tim Drake they're all on the phone and
they want to know what they should do
and Batman's response is tell him to
stand down I'll bring him in and it's
what do this this is this is one of the
coolest things ever because what happens
is Jason Todd initially has his cloaking
device and that shuts down you know that
basically shuts down so he's available
to the police and of course they're like
hey you gotta stop you know my kind of
stuff and so his response is okay I'm
not dealing with cops right now I got
more important things to worry about his
intention is to race off in a jump on
this ship to board it and then to work
alongside Artemis and and bizarro to
stop her from crashing into Gotham as
soon as he jumps off the bat rope comes
flying out grabs him by the leg and
Yanks him down and it's just like damn
because it's crazy I love the way Scott
Adele does this right because it's like
well the boss is home the boss is back
and he is very very angry and it's just
like damn dude and and here's here's the
thing here's here's a crazy thing about
this like you and expect a fight between
like Jason Todd and Batman to be like
drawn out and superval none enough
Batman makes quick work of them I mean
it's just it's a kick to the face it's a
block shot it's a backhand and Jason
Todd's down but it's kind of a cool
moment because what this does is it
really shows Jason's hod in comparison
to Batman it really shows that he just
doesn't really seem a chance right like
you were never on my level I just led
you to believe you were Batman just like
takes a tool and just starts pummeling
him but Bizarros swoops and smashes
Batman through the building grabs Jason
Todd and leaves and says Artemis told me
to come and get you and is crazy because
at this moment bizarro
has severely regressed he's gone back to
the almost almost of the way he was
before
and in this instant they that they don't
really seem to know exactly what it is
they can do here like there doesn't
really seem to be a way to shut the ship
down because the the auto-destruct
system is tied into Bizarros knowledge
and that knowledge is essentially gone
and so there's no real way to end it and
so what ends up happening here is
Bizzaro opens it opens a door to like
the time and space dimension you know
like the one thing that he's still
cognizant of he says you know I think
though anywhere in any time and he takes
off through the door you know intending
to go back in time long enough to stop
any of this from happening and so when
that happens he races out he's basically
gone the ship essentially blinks away
along with it but along the way Artemis
and Jason Todd finally kissed thank God
Scott Liddell even they've been dancing
around us long enough and anybody who
was reading red hood in the outlaws knew
it was only a matter of time before
these two started started bumpin uglies
everybody knew it was only a matter of
time before that habit but Artemis
basically throws him out she's like you
know somebody has to go after bizarro
it's gonna be me she throws him out of
the ship and then she blinks away just
kind of teleports away along with it but
we have no clue where they've gone to
after Jason Todd this is crushing
because in one fell swoop everything
he'd lost his come crashing down in a
singular night he got letters from his
father realizing his father wasn't
nearly as bad as he was heated up
learning that his mother seemingly
overdosed because her father his father
introduced her into drugs and into drugs
in the first place he ends up killing
Oswald Cobblepot Bizarros regressed back
down to his current form he disappears
in a ship alongside Artemis the whole
world of Jason Todd is essentially gone
and when Jason Todd is standing there
Andy's morning he asked Batman he's like
you're standing behind me aren't you and
he immediately goes to attack Batman
blocks punches
Jason Todd's down and that's it and it's
just like wow I mean it's just it's
insane to see just how easily crushed he
was by Bruce Wayne and you would kind of
expect that because Bruce Wayne is a
teacher I mean he's the original but
it's super cool to see this whole thing
unfold and so in response to this when
Batman goes to take Jason Todd
eventually take him back to where he's
gonna take him the Batcave or what have
you there's suddenly an arrow that snaps
right into Batman bright in the Batman
Select shuts down the part of his suit
red smoke goes everywhere knocks him out
and Arsenal picks up Jason Todd and says
I got you man and they end up getting
out of there with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here two comments
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the robb for if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
you